c'est une place où il y a tout un tas de
boutiques de luxe c'est certainement la
place d'ailleurs la plus luxueuse de
Paris d'accord et voilà il y a un camion
noir 6h du matin carré vise gare devant
la vitrine de chez Cartier le hayon
s'ouvre l'éléphant énorme un éléphant
et donc l'éléphant fond sur la vitrine
de chez Cartier il casse la vitrine bien
sûr avec sa trompe il pique tout et
bijoux il remonte et remonter dans le
camion et le le camion il part le
commissaire arrive deux heures plus tard
et il dit au seul témoin de l'affaire
c'est un petit garçon de café qui
installe sa terrasse qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu il raconte il y a un gros camion
noir l'éléphant a cassé avait très la
piqué bijoueur le camion le camion est
parti
et le commissaire il dit vous avez
l'immatriculation du camion vous avez
noté c'est une blague ou quoi on dit
j'insiste un truc complètement dingue ni
vous croyez que je me suis amusé à